this morning we have a follow-up
investigation from 60 minutes and the
Washington Post on the opioid crisis it
kills nearly 100 people every day 100
people in the first joint investigation
out in October whistleblowers revealed
how a new law weakened the DA's ability
to stop suspicious drug shipments within
the US this new investigation focus on
the biggest or pealed case the DEA ever
pursued against a drug company retired
DEA agent Dave Schiller spoke for the
first time to 60 minutes he says that
the settlement against drug company MCUs
in' was too lenient here's a preview of
bill Whitaker's report this is the best
case we've ever had against a major
distributor in the history of the Drug
Enforcement raishin how do we not go
after the number one organization in the
height of the epidemic when people are
dying everywhere doesn't somebody have
to be held accountable McKesson needs to
be held accountable
holding McKesson accountable meant going
after the fifth largest corporation in
the country headquartered in San
Francisco McKesson has 76,000 employees
and earns almost 200 billion dollars a
year in revenues about the same as Exxon
Mobil since the 1990s McKesson has made
billions from the distribution of
addictive opioids before he retired in
August Schiller had supervised dinh
vestigation Zin drug trafficking and
money laundering cases but he considered
the case against McKesson to be the
single most important investigation of
his lifetime what did they do that was
wrong the issue with McKesson was they
were providing millions and millions and
millions of pills to countless
pharmacies throughout the United States
and they did not maintain any sort of
due diligence this wasn't just happening
in Denver Colorado this was happening in
Los Angeles California it was happening
in Detroit Michigan it was happening in
New York City it was a national problem
and nobody wanted to deal with it we are
now joined by Bill Whitaker in the
Washington Post health reporter that's
Lenny Bernstein back again at the table
your first report guys as you know was
jaw-dropping for a lot of people who
didn't were not aware and saw that what
you revealed for the very first time
now you're back saying about DEA and
McKesson together what are they what is
the accusation this time what is it well
the nation the DEA requires that drug
distributors like McKesson report what
they call suspicious orders and these
are orders that are unusually large or
of unusual frequency and back in 2008
McKesson paid a more than 13 million
dollars in a settlement because the DEA
says that they were sending huge numbers
of suspicious orders around the country
shortly after they signed that
settlement DEA investigators saw
McKesson doing pretty much the same
thing sending thousands and thousands
and thousands of suspicious orders
around the country and they said that
since this was the second time that they
found the company doing it they wanted
to come down hard on them they wanted to
use them as an example to the rest of
the industry they wanted to come down
hard but the attorneys in Washington the
DEA attorneys in Washington they were a
little more lenient and that's what our
story's about
Eleni why were they more lenient where
was the gap there between the DEA and
the lawyers well you know if you watch
cop shows you know the investigators are
always aggressive and the attorneys are
always a little bit more cautious and
the attorneys have to evaluate what can
we prove what can we actually win in
court and there is a very large divide
between those two sides in this case
what we didn't realize when the
negotiated settlement was announced in
January was how big the gap was how
egregious the conduct of McKesson was
and why the investigators thought this
was worth so much larger of a punishment
did the lawyers have a specific problem
was it about motivation from McKesson
you know in other words it could have
just been sloppy behavior not intent was
that what the gap was intent is always
difficult to prove in court that's
always a stumbling block what the
investigators said and you'll you'll see
on Sunday is we had intent they knew
what they were doing in a couple of
cases we could prove it
the lawyers disagree it sounds like some
of the politicians felt that they were
duped by this law including Joe Manchin
from West Virginia a state that has a
huge opioid crisis well that's what we
found we went down to Washington and we
were talking to senators there and they
were saying that what for the law that
we did the first piece about that the
DEA said sort of tied their hands when
it came to going after these these
companies the lawmakers it was only a
three page law many of them said they
didn't know what was in it what was my
cousin's response to your investigation
we tried to get someone from the Kissin
McKesson to talk to us on camera and
they declined but we spoke to the lead
attorney many times through the course
of this and he basically told us that
the company and the DEA lawyers all
agreed that it was fruitless to look
back and go back over alleged
wrongdoings excuse me that what they
wanted to do from now on was look
forward and going forward the company
said that it would no longer behave like
this and the DEA now has an independent
monitor in place to watch the company
make sure that they behaved all right
they would occur in Lenny Bernstein
thanks so much and you can see the full
investigation of the DEA is biggest
opioid case in Sunday's edition of The
Washington Post and then Sunday night on
60 minutes right here on CBS